We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two.
David P. Here is a pretty straightforward
question.
And and I have a pretty straightforward answer
from one of our voicemail callers.
Take a listen.
Is a big fan of the show.
If he married me, I was in the Beaumont area.
I live in all of high world communities.
Maya will show us how much stupidity can just
blatant disregard for the show.
Can Republicans say a lot?
In my opinion, there's lessons might come
down to how well Thompson B.S., I would add.
I think he could do that rather well.
But I just I thought I was around as many
Republicans.
I don't understand how they can believe everything
they can brainwash.
And I did look at so.
So.
So there's actually there's a lot of things
that are different that are going on.
You have a contingent of people who support
Trump because they they are cognitively limited,
that they're sort of they're ignorant, they're
ignorant to what's going on and they lack
critical thinking skills.
So they just fall for stuff.
That's one component.
Number two, there are people on the right
who are going to vote for Trump's reelection
merely to own the Libs, as they like to say.
They've refused to consider voting for a Democrat,
despite the fact that Hillary Clinton and
Joe Biden have been very centrist Democrats
in in a lot of ways.
And on principle, in order to, you know, attack
or win against liberals, they just are going
to vote for Donald Trump's reelection.
That's another contingent.
You've got a third contingent, that is people
that recognize the dishonesty and the lies.
But they see recognizing this by voting for
someone else as kind of like admitting that
they failed, that they got tricked in 2016.
So there is like a cognitive dissonance that's
going on here.
A lot of voters can't abandon Trump because
of what it would say about them.
Right.
And so that's another component.
And then there is another contingent that
actually benefits from Trump's policy.
They're able to, you know, run businesses
extra profitably as the regulatory apparatus
of the United States looks away under Trump
or whatever.
Right.
They have some personal stake and they say
the hell to hell with everybody else.
So there is not one answer and there is stupidity.
There is tolerance of lies.
But there's a lot more to it than just that.
But a very, very good question and well said.
I hope that you will join the second David
Pakman show chess tournament.
It's going to be Tuesday, June 18th at 8:00
p.m. Eastern Time.
It's open to everybody, all skill levels.
It'll be on Lee Chess, dawg.
That's l.
I. Chess dot org.
You can register now and then I'll be streaming
my participation in the chess tournament.
We had 500 players in the first one.
I hope we do better than that this time around.
We also have a great bonus show coming up
for you today.
We will talk about the burning of a police
precinct and the degree of approval among
the American public for it.
I'll preview for you that it's quite low.
Number two, the program COPS has been canceled
in the wake of what is going on with George
Floyd.
And number three, the dictionary.
Merriam Webster will be updating its definition
of racism in light of what is going on.
All of these stories and more on today's bonus
show.
Two ways to access it.
Become a member at join Pacman dot com or
become a patron at Patrie on dot com slash
David Pakman show.
I'll see you then.